straight ahead on lawn crime daily the
woman convicted of killing her two
children and the wife of her now husband
is forced to sit and listen to the
impact it had on those left behind
because of the choices you made my
family lost a beloved mother sister aunt
and daughter
she is irreplaceable
she was one thousand times the woman you
will ever dream of being Lori is
undeniably a monster a monster that has
not taken any responsibility or shown an
ounce of remorse for her vile actions
she deserves to never again breathe
oxygen as a free member of society and
Lori herself speaks in court I mourn
with all of you who Morton my children
and Tammy
Jesus Christ knows the truth of what
happened here
Jesus Christ knows that no one was
murdered in this case
lawn crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to Long crime
daily I'm Jesse Weber our gavel to gavel
coverage of the trial of Doomsday cult
Mom Lori valo dabel comes to a close
with the sentencing phase but before the
judge imposed her sentence dabell had a
chance to give her own statement and not
only did she not take accountability for
the deaths of three people she seemed
glad they were gone take a listen
I would like to start by
quoting John from the New Testament in
the Bible
in John chapter 8 verse 7 Jesus says he
that is without sin among you let him
cast First cast a stone at her
then in first verse 15 Jesus says ye
judge after the flesh I judge no man and
yet if I judge my judgment is true
Jesus knows me
and Jesus understands me
I mourn with all of you who more my
children and Tammy
Jesus Christ knows the truth of what
happened here
Jesus Christ knows that no one was
murdered in this case
accidental deaths happen
suicides happen
fatal side effects from medications
happen
I have a different perspective in life
because in 2002 when I was pregnant with
Tyler I died in the hospital
while in labor with her
they tried to stop my labor they put me
on the table and they put something in
my IV and I felt my spirit falling to
the floor
I was standing near my pregnant body
watching the doctors try to revive me
which took them a few minutes
in that time
my sister Stacy was standing to my left
I turned to hug her and was surprised
that her spirit was as tangible as a
physical body
because I knew I was in spirit and she
was in spirit
she said she needed to show me some
things and we went to heaven
I later returned to my body
because of this experience I have access
to heaven and the spirit world
since then I have had many
Communications from people now living in
heaven
including my children Tyler Ashland and
Joshua Jackson
my sisters Stacy and Lolly my aunts and
my uncles and my grandparents
I have had many Communications with
Jesus Christ the savior of this world
and our Heavenly parents
I've had many Angelic visitors have come
and communicated with me and even
manifested themselves to me
because of these communications I know
for a fact that my children are happy
and busy in the spirit world
because of my communications with my
friend Tammy daybell I know that she is
also very happy and extremely busy
I have always mourned the loss of my
loved ones and I have lost many in this
mortal world
however
I know them more than most people I know
where they are now and what they're
doing I know how wonderful Heaven is and
I'm homesick for it every single day
I know we all lived in heaven before we
were born on Earth and we were all adult
spirits in the Heavenly realm we chose
to come to Earth as Mortals
Heaven is more wonderful than you can
possibly imagine
I do not fear death but I look forward
to it
I do not I did not want to return to my
body when I was out of it even though my
son Colby who I adored more than
anything was only six years old at the
time and I was about to give birth to
this new baby girl that I wanted so
badly
as you digest that we're gonna take a
quick break with more of Lori
valadevel's statements at her sentencing
when we come back stay with us
and welcome back to Long crime daily
everybody so we're continuing our
coverage of Lori valadebell sentencing
after she was convicted of killing her
two children and conspiring to murder
her husband's deceased wife she was
given the opportunity to speak for the
judge imposed his sentence of life in
prison and she had a lot to say
I was a young mother and you would think
I wouldn't want to leave my children but
as I stood in heaven I did not want to
go back I thought they would be fine
without me because I was peaceful and I
was happy and I was home
but then I was told by Jesus that I
needed to go back and complete things
that I had covenanted or promised to do
before I was born
this caused me a lot of distress because
I knew heaven was my real home and I
only wanted to be there I was free from
Pain emotional and physical
but then I was shown how I would help my
children and others in the future so
ultimately I did agree to go back to my
body
Kylie has visited me
she is happy and very busy
Kylie is free now from all the Pains of
her life
Tyler suffered horrible physical pain
her whole life
I sat with Kylie in the hospital year
after year after year while she screamed
in pain when the morphine wasn't even
enough to take away the pain of her
pancreatitis I sat there while she cried
and I held back her hair while she threw
up and I am the only person on this
Earth who knows how much tylie suffered
in her life she had pain every single
day she never felt good
her body did not work right and I don't
know if that was from complications for
me dying while she was being born or
something else but she had a very
difficult life
she was sexually abused by her own
biological father since she was three
years old and she was forced by Family
Court to go visit him for 10 years
against her will
I fought for her
in court I protected her I tried to
protect her with my whole life I tried
to protect her I worried about her every
single day
Tyler had to get her GED because she
couldn't go to school every day because
she never felt good she felt sick
nobody knows this because Tyler like
myself tries to put on a good front
tries to be a happy person tries to have
hope in life tries to know that she's
here for a purpose and that she has an
eternal purpose to be on this Earth but
I never stopped worrying about her
one of the times that Tyler came to me
as a spirit after she died she said she
commanded me and she said to me stop
worrying Mom we are fine
she knows how I worry and how I miss her
the first time JJ visited me after he
passed away
he put his arm around me and he said to
me
you didn't do anything wrong Mom
I love you
and I know you loved me every minute of
my life
JJ Joshua Jackson
was an adult spirit and he was very very
tall when he put his arm around me
he is busy he is engaged he has jobs
that he does there and he is
happy where he is his life was short but
JJ's life was meaningful JJ was a
wonderful person and touched the lives
of everyone and I adored him every
minute of his life
my eternal friend Tammy dabell has
visited me on several occasions
she came to bring me peace and comfort
and I know that she is extremely busy
helping her family especially her
children and grandchildren and I have a
great love for tammys
my beautiful children Kylie Ashland and
Joshua Jackson rest safely This Day In
the Arms of Jesus my wonderful friend
Tammy day Bell rests safely this day
In the Arms of Jesus
and I look forward to the day when we
are all reunited and I too will rest
with them in the arms of my Jesus
just wild stuff and now that we've heard
all Lori had to say let me bringing my
co-host legal analyst Terry Austin Brian
buckmire Terry I'll start with you I was
shocked she made a statement were you I
mean what did you think of that I did
not expect her to get up there and make
a statement I didn't know what she was
going to say one of the things that she
said that really hit home was
there are accidental deaths there are
deaths that happen by Suicide there are
deaths that happen because of
consequences of medication so this is
what I think she is telling herself how
these deaths occurred even though
obviously from the autopsies we know
exactly well not everyone but we know
partially how these happen the fact that
JJ had a bag over his head he was taped
up the fact that Tyler you know was
stabbed probably based on what they
found but if she felt Justified she
never even explain what it is like okay
I feel right about it she never
explained it she never did she never
explained it and she never took any
responsibility and she did not have
remorse that lack of remorse makes me
wonder if this should have been a death
penalty case and that's a question that
I had as well again not a proponent of
the death penalty whatsoever but I as an
attorney I'm comparing Apples to Apples
so I look at Idaho and I say okay do you
have any women on death row they have
one her name is Robin Rowe she was
convicted for setting fire to a home or
her husband and two children died if I'm
comparing Roe to valo they seem pretty
similar to me especially when you see
the method with these children are
killed and her lack of remorse I think
the prosecutors are second thinking
maybe we should have put death in the
table how does it affect you actually
they put it on the table but the judge
took it off because the defense made a
motion that's right removed the death
penalty because of Discovery violations
and various other things they were
saying that the public knew all about it
she wasn't going to get a fair trial but
the judge because of the discovery
violations took it off the table and if
you recall the defense when he got up to
speak here said listen it's nobody's
fault this is what should have happened
it wasn't prosecution it wasn't the
judge it wasn't us it should not have
been on the table real quick you think
they're going to do death penalty for
Chad I think so yeah after everything
that we've seen in this case absolutely
go go for him because they made an error
as to why she didn't have it thank you
correcting Terry then I think they'll go
for it against Chad all right well while
Laurie got her time in the spotlight
Monday sentencing hearing was really
about the victims and the impact of
their loss you're going to hear the
words of a heartbroken grandmother has
for the woman who took away her Joy
that's next
so welcome back to Long crime daily
everybody we're focusing today on the
sentencing hearing for Lori vallo dabel
the so-called doomsday cult mom who
killed her own children Laurie was
convicted of killing her two children
J.J valo and Tyler Ryan after the
remains were found buried on the
property of her newest husband Chad
dabel Laurie was also convicted of
conspiring to kill Chad's first wife
Tammy dabell who died just weeks before
Lori and Chad got married in Hawaii
several people read Victim Impact
statements during Monday's sentencing
hearing some of the most powerful words
came from K Woodcock the grandmother who
took JJ in as a premature baby caring
for him for the first part of his life
we never know when one of those moments
are going to hit but I can tell you that
there have been too many situations in
the past few years where we get slammed
with the fact that JJ won't hit another
milestone in his life
all because it's materialistic
self-centered mother cruelly and
brutally stole his life and him from the
world
's accident depravity cruelty and
betrayal have no limits Terry those were
some strong words what'd you think I
thought Kate a great job you know the
two of them Larry and Kay they
practically raised JJ because remember
that's her grandchild that is the child
of her son so Kay is the sister of
Charles so that's how it comes she's so
connected and they took care of him he
was premature and they laid him on top
of them he had this very close
relationship to Larry because Larry used
to take care of him when he was upset or
crying and I thought it was very
poignant what she did she tried to take
numbers and put some sort of value on
those numbers and she went through his
entire life and it was really hard to
hear because
you know took away JJ from her took away
Tyler from her and it had a lasting
impact on both K and Larry and I think
people felt that and understood it I
think the Judge understood that too
that's my that's the question I always
have do you think the Judge went into
this already knowing what his sentence
was going to be for each of these
charges or does the judge you think the
Judge actually listened to these words
and was affected and changed his
decision based on the victim impact
statements I think nine times out of ten
judges go in knowing what they want to
do but there might be some
a sense of like not being quite sure but
I think in the way that he expressed
himself and the way that he came down
with the consecutive sentences for three
of the charges one for each murder he
could have done consecutive for five and
now the other two conspiracy but he
didn't I think he was very thoughtful
and he thought about what was said and I
think it reassured him that he made the
right decision I don't think it changed
his mind but I think it definitely
reassured he's like I'm doing the right
thing from what I heard and we also
heard the statement from Colby Ryan uh
Lori's son wasn't he wasn't there it was
read by the attorney do you think that
had an effect I think it was effective I
think it was short and sweet but I think
the Judge listened to it and I think one
of the things that was said about Colby
is those phone records Kay mentioned it
when she was doing her statement the
phone records the jail call and how
difficult that call was for Colby
listening to his mom trying to get his
mom to understand and to admit and to
talk about it this is his family his
whole family now is gone from you know
his sister and brother and now his
mother's going to be in jail and it was
very difficult for him he didn't even
have to make a statement that call in
and of itself is in the mind of the
judge and I think one of the most
powerful things Kobe said in that call
was there were other things we could
have done I would have taken those kids
in instead of you killing them and that
is a big theme there were other options
here if you didn't want him in your life
if you didn't want to be a part of you
want to be a mother anymore there are
other things to do well when we come
back the judge has the final word in
that courtroom as he hands down Lori
vallo daybell's prison sentence
[Music]
and welcome back everybody the judge in
Lori valadebell's case has seen every
part of this story from the defendant's
competency evaluations to the gruesome
crime scene photos to the wild ideas
related to her religious beliefs he had
the final word in court on Monday take a
look
and it is the most shocking thing really
I can imagine is that a mother killed
her own children and you simply have no
remorse for it even sitting here today
there's no remorse for what you did
after all of this evidence through trial
you haven't shown any remorse you
haven't said you're sorry
you haven't done anything
to seek leniency from this court I don't
believe that any God in any religion
would want to have
have this happen what happened here
and your crimes are heinous and
egregious
and that alone can constitute a major
aggravating Factor
it requires me to impose a serious
length of incarceration yeah he seemed
so thoughtful Brian and careful in his
consideration and giving three
consecutive life sentences what was your
reaction to the way he handled that so I
always think about all these cases as a
defense attorney and I actually really
like the defense attorney's arguments
here they just have a really bad case
yeah but the argument that when you give
someone Max determinant life with no
parole meaning you're just there for the
rest of your life there's no parole no
nothing there's really no difference
between one life with no parole and 20
life no parole it's life is life you
don't have multiple lives Laurie May
believe that but the rest of us just
have one right but his explanation of
why he doesn't do it and why this made
sense I thought was perfect and
beautiful for all the victims here each
one of those lives mattered and he
deserved she deserves to serve a
sentence for each one of those lives he
could have gone all the way and said I'm
going to conseque you for five life
sentences he says no I'm stopping at
three the rest are concurrent and I
think he was thoughtful and even the
smallest of charges it was a little bit
of a roller coaster because he started
out listing all the mitigating factors
and a part of me thought is he going to
Grant a parole is she going to get
something less than life in prison if
possible but he didn't right thank
goodness he didn't because this should
have been the maximum and he did do the
maximum that he could or at least most
of the maximum so in the beginning he's
giving them mitigating circumstances and
so those mitigating factors included the
fact that she'd never had a crime before
she's already 50 years old and you know
he took that into consideration and I
just thought that at first like you he
was not going to give her you know the
life without parole at least one life
without parole because he was saying
very favorable things about it he said
that she was well behaved in court that
she was respectful which I think some
people would disagree and in fact in
some of those impact statements people
were disagreeing with that and the judge
said some may disagree with this so he
was going on and on and I got a little
bit concerned but what he was doing was
protecting the record making sure he put
on the record what are the mitigating
factors what are the aggravating factors
and making sure it's all safe and
clearly those aggravating factors
outweighed any mitigation in this case
Brian Terry thank you both so much
everyone out there thanks for joining us
here on Long crimes daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss Justice in
America